tom holland
just messed with
all of us him zendaya
jacob they all mess with us hardcore
i saw tom holland put out that phone
home thing i was like that sounds weird
and then unfortunately before
hopping on to do a video right away i
saw that uh jacob put out one two and i
was like okay there's some just trolling
going oh but he's gonna be on jimmy
fountain i don't know let's just mean it
and so many people must have watched
jimmy fallon tonight just to see
the title revealed just to be there in
the moment
when he reveals the title
he didn't do it
and they played a game like instant
spoilers with tom holland and you're
like this is it
this is when they're gonna do it this is
when they're gonna do it
i don't know what the point of this was
maybe it was maybe it was uh the team
behind uh
jimmy fallon as a way to as a way to get
more viewership for the tonight show
i don't really watch the tonight show to
be honest so you know
it was the only reason i was watching
the segment it was just in case
but man you know
i was talking with uh warren my buddy
from uh cosmic wonder
it's very evident he's very much
frustrated by the situation
he um he has to have a surgery in the
morning and he stayed up late
just in case because you know all most
of his content or pretty much all of it
is
about marvel's so he had to stay up late
in case they dropped the title something
he's been
really waiting for and there's a lot of
fans who are really upset
about not getting that title revealed
today
and i'm at this point i'm like can
can whatever the title be can it
possibly live up
to all the hype is now there's more hype
than ever
just to get the reveal of this title
like this better be the best [ __ ]
title in the world
this better be the best goddamn title
that's ever been
said in all the marvel history at this
point it's such a it's such a big thing
and
i'm like am i upset at tom holland and
all them for doing this
like what how do i feel about it
i don't know it's kind of funny to me
like it's all a big troll
and there's so many of us who are
waiting for it so i i know by me saying
that it's
it's kind of funny the reason why it's
funny is because it's not like we're
never gonna get it
it's not like we're never going to have
the title
told to us we're eventually at some
point this year
going to have unless they push the movie
back or something because i'm now i'm
like maybe they'll wait
the way how they did like avengers end
game maybe they'll wait to reveal the
title when the actual trailer comes out
but i'm i'm at a point where i'm like
we're eventually going to get it and
they know what they're doing they knew
exactly what they were doing obviously
so i guess it makes sense that they have
a little bit of fun with it
but at the same time i i do see how it's
like kind of a messed up thing to do in
advance because
we've all been itching for like a teaser
trailer and more information on it and
and you know as he's been trying to just
promote cherry he just keeps getting
asked about spider-man
so i i don't know i don't know whose
idea this was
but i think like whoever's annoyed right
now
uh i think by the time we get the title
we'll we'll be like all right we got the
title but now the question is
will that title live up will it be like
will it be some mind-blowing thing we're
like oh my god the endless possibilities
what will it be
so my question to you guys what do you
think the title will ultimately be
what if it is just one of the ones that
the cast posted
what if it is just like phone home funny
would that be
uh what do you want the title to be what
are you hoping it implies leave your
thoughts down below
tell me if you're annoyed tell me if you
find the situation kind of funny
see you guys